hi I'm Erik Bosse and Venom is the next
big movie on the nerd door and there was
one interesting detail from the recent
trailer that still not a lot of people
were talking about why is there a Life
Foundation space shuttle visible in the
background of some of this footage and
we know that the Venom symbiote scum
from outer space that's the crash ships
that we've seen in all the trailers but
why might these villainous characters
want to go back to space are we looking
at venom in space let's break down two
possible theories and yeah spoiler
warning in case any of these are too
right first let's look closely at the
two shots I'm referring to the verse
shows venom landing on an industrial
catwalk with the lid up space shuttle
launch pad behind him we can assume this
is part of a fight with riot another
symbiote attached to RZA meds villain
character Carlton Drake because there's
also a shot of the two inky pukes
slapping each other right at the base of
the shuttle on which you can see the
words light foundation printed now last
July at Comic Con we learned that Drake
and Life Foundation are interested in
space exploration so this is an updated
version of Carlton Drake and the light
foundation from the Marvel Comics
they're the light foundation is more of
a survivalist cult that planned for what
would come after what they saw as the
inevitable nuclear holocaust between the
US and the Soviet Union's their plan was
to construct new proof communities where
the elite of society could pay five
million dollars for entry which by the
way five million dollars if that were
applied to now the next generation
society would be bred from all the wrong
youtubers in this movie the global
threat is environmental and omits
description leads us to our first space
theory the light foundation is
evacuating earth perhaps the space
shuttle that we see in the venom footage
is carrying a bunch of light foundation
bigwigs Sultan's kids and merch pushing
streamers all to escape a dying earth to
live on a new space colony we're
especially talking about the plan for
the movie interstellar which you know
kind of glossed over the fact that
billions of Earthlings died and dust
storms while a select few surviving a
big space tube with McConaughey museums
ah not alright alright alright this
theory would be interesting but you know
it does
account for drinks focus on human
experiments what about the allegations
that you recruit the most vulnerable for
tests that end up killing people and in
another trailer Drake opened up this way
human beings are disposable and species
and that leads us to space theory to the
light foundation is sending super
soldiers to invade other planets
maybe this discovery of the alien
symbiote showed that when these things
bond with humans they enhance the
human's physical strength and durability
to make it easier for them to survive in
space and on hostile planets we know
from the footage of the Venom symbiote
can repair broken limbs and give its
hosts super-strength
who knows maybe it also doesn't need to
breathe oxygen then maybe you could just
be used as an organic space exoskeleton
that tries to take over your mind still
worth it we've seen this kind of idea in
sci-fi too in the back stories of things
like Blade Runner and altered carbon you
know where artificial humans are
developed with extreme durability and
strength to fight two super soldiers
across the galaxy and I guess to you
know work as super farmers and super
construction workers to build better
worlds on the other side of the galaxy
right the way venom positions himself
away from the space shuttle in this
footage fighting riot as if he's trying
to keep them off of that shuttle brings
me to space theory 3 the light
foundation has lost control of the
symbiotes which are trying to take over
Earth and beyond so in addition to the
venom lethal protector comic storyline
this movie script is also apparently
pulling inspiration from the planet of
the symbiote series and that arc venom
explains the symbiote homeworld of Clint
are in the Andromeda galaxy where the
symbiotes are part of a race intent on
taking over host bodies of other races
so that they can feel emotion but the
Venom symbiote wanted to simply bond
with the hosts rather than dominate them
so they considered him a freak a freak
who just wants to love so venom in
spider-man in obtaining up to stop this
invasion force of other symbiotes that
build a teleporter to earth that they
can take it over I'm not sure if the
movie will go that far and it sounds
like spider-man Peter Parker will not be
in this movie but a recent TV spot
showed Carlton Drake and what appears to
be some mission controlling looking in
command center with satellite navigation
on some of the screens that looks a lot
like the same location that we've seen
in other
with rows of computer terminals you know
the ones that riot swipes away like a
sore loser Catan perhaps riot overtakes
Drake as an even worse villain aiming to
hijack the light foundation spaceships
to return to their Clint our homeworld
and maybe spread their symbiote virus to
neighboring planets and it would make
sense for why venom Eddie Brock as a
relatively good guy trying to stop worse
symbiotes from spreading would want to
stop right from getting on this spatial
comment down below with your thoughts on
which of these theories sound the most
plausible and interesting to you and
follow me on Twitter and Instagram it he
gave us four other projects I'm working
on like this video shared around and
subscribe to new rock stars for
everything venom related including our
best guesses at whatever venom is trying
to say in these clips we don't street
sounds right to me
[Music]